- [Narrator] This is the bateleur eagle.
Shrinking habitats, and
inadvertent poisoning,
has caused a major drop in this
majestic bird's population.
(gentle piano music)
Bateleurs are medium-sized birds.
But they have a wingspan of over six feet.
They have dark black feathers under their
white wings, with a red face, and legs.
While endemic to most parts of Africa,
they prefer the open woodland savannas,
or the grasslands.
The name Bateleur is French
for tightrope walker,
and references their
distinctive flight pattern.
Unlike most birds, they fly low to
the ground when hunting for prey.
They feed on small birds and mammals,
but are also carrion eaters.
Unfortunately, farmers will poison dead
carcasses to kill off predators,
and bateleurs end up ingesting
the highly toxic poisons.
This the bateleur eagle.